if you're in a highly competitive market
you need to stand for something if you
want to stand out hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help so today amazing a question
from one of my face book readers am on
who wrote in saying I just started a pub
and grill can you gives him the give me
advice and how to attract more customers
and expand saumon is in a situation a
lot of people can relate to it's a hard
business to start restaurants have the
highest failure of almost any business
out there it's so competitive there's a
lot of cost to get this thing going and
it's hard to stand out you have to find
a way to stand for something and be
known for something to separate yourself
from the crowd you should not just be
another pub and grill you have to be
known for having the best whatever why
should people come to your pub and grill
over anybody everybody else's what is
special about you it could be you have a
special recipe it could be your staff
really believes in something you have a
guiding mission for the business
something give me something to latch on
to it doesn't even have to be related to
the food that you're selling I'm based
here in Toronto Canada we have bars that
are designated as the Manchester United
bar and every week many new soccer fans
will pack the bar in the morning to
watch their game together that's their
bar because the owners a big fan and so
he set it up that way and people now
have loyalty to this bar over everybody
else they'll drive in from all the way
across town to go to that specific bar
and when they're looking for a bar to
hang out at on a day when menu isn't
plane what do you think they're going to
go they're going to go to their favorite
bar the one they have all the happy
memories in so you need to create that
for your business
and you have to express it in all the
messaging that comes across you should
no longer just be another pub and grill
you are the pub and grill that is known
for what this applies to any
entrepreneur who is in a competitive
business if you're a photographer if
your website developer if your real
estate agent whatever it is you have to
be known for something you can't just be
another photographer a real estate agent
there's too many of them you have to be
known for something you have to stand
for something so you can stand out good
luck I hope you apply it to your
business for those of you watching
please give the video a thumbs up if you
liked it i love seeing those come in and
if you have a question about this video
or question about your own business i'd
love to hear from you i always read it
in the comments so please leave a
comment and i will see you on the next
episode
you
you